just a little bit of salt not too much
salt just a little
[Music]
hey what's up everybody i'm maddie
mathison and today with gq i'm going to
show you how to make the greatest blt
you've ever seen there's a lot of good
things to do there's a lot of bad things
to do but in the middle there's
greatness we're here today making the
greatest blt of all time ha
blt that's a bacon lettuce and tomato
sandwich
i think the blt is one of the greatest
sandwiches of all time literally of the
entire history of the planet there's the
bacon the lettuce the tomato
the mayonnaise
and the bread right here in front of us
bacon streaky bacon crispy bacon you
make it crispy you don't you don't make
it soggy
oh
oh
this is like butcher bacon fat crispy
this is the one i'm using okay this is
the good stuff
green leaf lettuce beautiful
ah
no
no
just an iceberg baby
tomatoes
tomato salted pepper nice and we're
gonna do a melange we're gonna cut it up
pretty much this is a tomato
sandwich with bacon and lettuce you know
there's two mayonnaises in the world
almonds and dukes those are the best
ones and this isn't even a [ __ ] ad
but dave's killer bread makes like the
most fire bread for at home just
throwing it in the toaster and i just
genuinely love this bread i think the
consistency the sweetness the seeds the
moisture the crunch everything that
happens the thickness that it's sliced
is perfect for blt
now i'm gonna put together the greatest
blt that i believe
exists okay so the first thing that i
gotta do before i start chopping up my
tomatoes and my lettuce i'm gonna toast
fresh we got some once again we got some
set decks some beautiful composition
toasted bread but we want some freshies
while the toast is toasted once again i
want it really toasted so we're going to
leave it in there the first thing i'm
going to do
is cut
our lettuce like in half
i think i'm going to cut it in half
again quarter it
and then i'm going to take out the one
little
loose kind of outer lettuces put that in
the bucket the thing that i like to do
if i was making multiple sandwiches i
would take the outer kind of cups here
and make that and then i would take kind
of the crunchier fatter wilder parts and
i build out like little lettuce cups and
kind of smush it down with your hands
and kind of crunch it into like a little
bit of a shape there
okay tomatoes
we're going to cut and slice our
tomatoes
and i'm just i'm not going to cut them
super thin
not going to cut them super fat
you got heirlooms you got vine ripe
tomatoes so once again with tomatoes and
shapes it's like you can cut it so many
different ways this tomato is kind of
longer than
higher so what i can do
is cut it in the middle like that
beautiful and then we can just slice
this
the main thing is we just want to make
them flat
oh i can smell the toast
yeah here we go okay okay this is
perfect
see that
we've done the hard work you got crispy
bacon we have fresh
toast now we put mayonnaise on a fair
amount be liberal be you know libs we
got our pepper mill
lace this with pepper
and season with just a little bit of
salt take your iceberg lettuce
put that on there
now
tomato
tomato get out okay there's two
black pepper we're layering
black pepper the thing about a great blt
is that it's seasoned not heavily
seasoned but just seasoned throughout
the amount of pepper may seem excessive
but it's right just a little bit of salt
even though we're seasoning kind of
every little level
it's still just a little bit of salt not
too much salt just a little
now we got tomatoes over here
layer these up oh yeah
and you can push down you can push down
pepper
just a little bit of salt
and then what i'm gonna do is two
yellows
little bit of salt
now
bacon
we got two
we take like one piece
and we build this up
one more three pieces
ripped in half
holy [ __ ] this is gonna be good
see that
see the thing about it check this out
yeah
here's like a regular blt okay look at
the difference here you go just imagine
if this was toasted okay
you got like three little [ __ ] pieces of
lettuce
boom boom
this is your typical
blt here okay
you cut it like this so we get some
perspective on this
you know like that's kind of like you
walk into a store you ask for like a blt
that's kind of what you get you know
kind of still fire it's amazing it's
great nothing really wrong with it but
this
this
that's mine okay
this is the way that i love to eat it
right the tomatoes the lettuce
this bread is dense enough and strong
enough to uphold it's not gonna fall
apart
this is it right here you lift up that
little blanket what's under the what's
under there
what's tucked away
that little gentle bedding
it's a little blt bedding and underneath
that it's just this
that's nice right there let me show you
how you eat it usually i eat this over a
garbage can
all my kids and trishy they're over
there hanging out at the table
big dog just made like six blt's for
everybody sunday this is sunday morning
every sunday when the tomatoes are
blooming
when they're freshies see look at that
oh
and then this is the thing you start
dripping
this is what should be happening
actually this is like a tomato
vinaigrette
and then you as you eat this you take
your other half and then you start
dipping in that okay here we go
[Applause]
that's good
not too salty
it's
okay we over the garbage can right now
baby
this is my favorite blt hopefully you
enjoy this if not
hit me up in the discord
tell me i'm a [ __ ] loser okay
have a great day
[Music]